金ちゃん肇社長です今日はですね学校は触れました
違う違う違うそうだけどそっっだけどちゃんとやることやってますちょっと部屋で勉強
してるんで今日はですね
特に
ブービーですけどなんか僕にこう言いたいパティだーでくださいっっ
小川のコメントにも質問でもいいし何か僕に聞きたいことはこれにこういった梅雨
ちゃいたいことがあったらもう全然書いてください
だ全部は無理だと思うんですけどできる限りできる限りそのコメントの開始を次の動画
で言って組んで質問コーナー強いなんか
僕に行ってみたいことみたいな感じですね
講師の動画で申し訳ないんですけど
なんかもうね竜車で登録者はズーマんにも言ってなかったのに全然どうだしないの日本
13万人にもなって頂いていて本当に皆さんに観察してるんで
ません
恩返しと者全然来たらなることなのですけれど
こいろいろなのかやっぱ僕は知らなきゃいけ日にはもう何も始まらないと思うんで
ほとんど貼ってるぜひコメントお願いします
コメントああそうだなそうだ
ん
この動画ですねこの動画のコメントにも聞きたいことかが何かを言ってやりたいと思う
皆さんコメントまってますとが次の動画で返します
なんか面白いコメントとかぜひ待ってるんで
しません
じゃん